In Somalia, at least ten people were killed and 20 others wounded...
...in a car bombing in the Somali capital of Mogadishu.
In North Korea, a senior North Korean official, speaking after the death...
...of a US student held prisoner for 17 months by Pyongyang,...
...said his country followed national law and international standards...
...in its treatment of detainees.
In Bosnia, around 300 high school students protested in Travnik on Tuesday...
...against national and ethnic segregation in Bosnian schools.
Emergency services in Portugal said...
...that they are making headway in their battle to control a major wildfire...
...that killed 64 people in the central area of the country,...
...but another blaze nearby grew in size and has caused concern.
And finally from Iran, the Revolutionary Guard said...
...that all six ballistic missiles it launched at Islamic State militants...
...in Syria earlier this week hit their targets.